où
voici l'histoire d'un petit fruit rouge
plus connu sur le nom de goyavier de
chine originaire de chine
non non non du brésil il s'est vite
développée dans les pays au climat chaud
et humide
à la réunion on le connaît sous le nom
de goyavier un fruit sucré de couleur
rouge brillante
il est tellement apprécié qu on le
déguste nature en gelée en sirop en
confiture en avant anglais s'en coller
un gâteau en pense ce petit arbuste
c'est tellement bien installé à la
réunion qui l'a rapidement colonisé les
bas et les forêts humides des eaux de
l'île devenant une espèce invasive
explications
une espèce invasive ou envahissante est
une espèce qui a été introduite par
l'homme ou par les animaux dans un
nouvel environnement naturel et le
développement de cette plante est
tellement important qu'ils menacent les
autres végétaux déjà présents sur ce
milieu notamment les espèces endémiques
une plante endémique est une plante que
l'on ne retrouve que sur un territoire
spécifique et nulle part ailleurs au
monde
par exemple à la réunion il existe près
de 250 espèces endémiques comme le en
bas ville le fleur jaune
le café bourbon pointu
à
on connaissait les qualités du fruit
mais il y a quelques années de cela un
petit groupe de personnes s'est
intéressé au bois de goyavier assez
longue tige danse est pourtant très
souple en décembre 2011 portée par le
conseil départemental et créer le
premier atelier de transformation du
bois de goyavier c'est au coeur de ces
forêts que des agents coupe le bois de
goyavier une récolte qui se fait tout au
long de l'année sur des espaces définis
par l'office national des forêts donc
c'est un double intérêt de faire cette
coupe donc ça tout d'abord ça permet de
créer une activité pour l'équipe qui
vient justement travailler ici et ça
leur permet de couper du goyavier et
ensuite cette coupe ça permet une
régénération naturelle des espèces qui
sont propres à la réunion donc on
retrouvera toutes les espèces endémiques
de la réunion qui pourront pousser
librement sur ces parcelles qui ont été
désinfectés en vigueur une fois coupé
les branches sont regroupés et
transporté à l'atelier de transformation
qui se trouve au chaudron
c'est ici qu'une quarantaine de
personnes travaillent le bois de
goyavier selon une méthode bien précises
la première étape de transformation
c'est l'étuvage c'est un grand bac on
met de l'eau à bouillir et on met le
bois
dans dans les tubes ça permet de rendre
le battre et souple pour le travail et
affi
oh
la deuxième étape de transformation le
braille sortie de l'étude
il a été chauffée on le passe dans le
raid reçoit re afin d'avoir une gaule
est bien droite pour la transformation
suivant
à
la troisième étape de transformation
c'est l'usinage le bois il arrive dans
cette pièce à l'aide de différentes
machines on va le pont c'est le coupé le
redresser le signe et le raboter afin
d'avoir des pièces qui nous serviront à
la fabrication des objets artisanaux
et une fois cette transformation opérée
le bois de goyavier est prêt à être
assemblés
vous pouvez voir dans cette salle une
grande partie des objets artisanaux
réalisés à partir de ce bois et bien
plus encore
hahaha
voilà les enfants nous sommes allés en
forêt pour découvrir la collecte du bois
de goyavier puis nous sommes allés à
l'atelier de production pour voir la
transformation de la matière maintenant
nous sommes à l'espace règle et où nous
pouvons découvrir les objets réalisés
par la fille à ouahigouya vie comme la
chaise pliante la petite chaise
spécialement pour les plus petits la
table en bois de goyavier et de paniers